it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little better all
that exclusive low discounts and during
women's History Month we'll share some
products from women-owned businesses
Michelle is clapping that's right give
it up for the ladies hello shopping now
scan the QR code on your screen right
now or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle host
and expert Elizabeth Warner joins us
right now how are you doing um well
thank you for having me and everyone's
cbsdeals.com shop with us I'm so excited
to show you this one Nike mussels yes
this is from calming heat and what I
love about this think of your favorite
heating pad your favorite massager and
your favorite weighted blanket this is
all of them in one so you've got heat
control and vibration control there are
three different heat settings nine
different vibration settings and then
inside it's Clay beads those beads hold
absorb that heat yeah and give you a
little bit of extra weight in there so
it's got that comfortable feeling on
pressure points you can use it on your
wrist your elbow your knee your neck
whatever you'd like because you can see
it's adjustable just like this Ryan
Crest had it on earlier yes yeah like
how does it feel and he said seriously
it feels really good yes they're really
really comfortable so right now 45 off
just 23.99 okay pickleball pickleball is
the fastest growing sport in America
people are going crazy for this it's
easily accessible they play indoors they
play Outdoors all ages well this is
Rockne this brand was created by Elise
Ivy that's right she's amazing there she
is she created this brand because she
wanted high-tech great products that
actually look good at the same time so
starting off with the Curve I'm gonna
hand you this one all right this is an
amazing paddle it's got a fiberglass
face to it that's going to give that
explosion to the ball when you hit it
inside a honeycomb that actually has a
large sweet spot so no matter where you
hit on this paddle you're going to get
that excellent hit and a little pretty
Surface by the way that helps with the
grip and with that ball spin but let's
move on to our curve X now our carbon X
carbon X this one is for the more
advanced player the pros all use these
if you played tennis ping pong or
badminton before this is sort of a combo
of all of them well this one is made of
carbon so the carbon is actually a
little lighter weight this one gives a
little more control for those better
players as you're moving up yep inside
feel that one that's got honeycomb
inside as well and when you hit it
you're going to be able to hit it
anywhere on there because of that
extended sweet spot it does so these are
on sale up to 50 off the curve is 69.99
and the carbon 50 off just
89.99
grab these now by the way tons of
accessories and sets all right all right
yes what I am I will I will try this
while you're talking okay yes so these
are from caloric these are our Cobra
knives now these are Hand Forged from a
single piece of high carbon stainless
steel you know what that means go ahead
what's the most important what's the
most important thing in the kitchen
right oh crap doing a good job don't
don't you know be safe don't worry now
when you when these are actually Hand
Forged like that that means that they're
put into heat and hand pounded down so
that's going to create that amazing
strength and sharpness most important
tool in the kitchen right that's nice
when you're prepping these are amazing
yes and these are coming in sets my
favorite set has all of everything
you're going to need from a chef set to
a prep to a paring knife we've got the
steak knives oh you cannot miss on the
sharpener as well this is an additional
purchase the price yeah okay all right
so 22 dollars to 38 dollars they are up
to 38 off and we're talking for sets
yeah best knives I don't know how you
make this water thank you so much and of
course for partnering with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything that you saw today scan the QR
code on your screen or head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now